hello and welcome everybody
to the 230 session my name is mike
weimerskirsch i am the director of
educational innovation for the
university of minnesota's
school of mathematics center for
educational programs
and today i'm going to talk to you about
a
project that we have worked with wolfram
on using web mathematica as the engine
to deliver homework to students
the name of this project is the
minnesota online
learning system moles for short moles is
delivering randomized homework
and quizzes to sixteen hundred
pre-calculus students
including as i speak i have 250 students
taking an exam right now
this also houses our placement exam that
over 7000 students each year coming to
the university of minnesota
take in order to get placed into
introductory level
math courses so
what is moles what is the modern day
approach
to students doing homework
we've gone away from pencil and paper as
most everybody has and we now have a
computer system
and all of these things are all pretty
much the same they have
four components first off you need
some content somebody has to write some
questions
and they need to be made available to
students
once the student is presented with a
question
they need to have an interface where
they can
answer the question once the student has
submitted an
answer something needs to determine
whether or not
what the author proposed as the answer
key
and what the student proposed as the
answer are the
same mathematical object and then the
instructors need to know
how well the students performed on the
assessments
and so these are the four parts that we
tried to
to build so how did we get here
in 2013 we decided
that we would flip the pre-calculus
classroom
pre-record lectures students watch those
at home
do homework in class except we didn't
actually
flip the classroom we did some other
affine
transformation to the class that i need
a
cool name for um there's a better idea
than just
calculate uh working on calculation
instead let's also do the homework at
home let's watch
videos and do the homework at home do
the skill building
and then use our class time to
do some other things the things down
here at the bottom of bloom's taxonomy
learn a procedure in order to perform a
certain calculation
those are important skills to have a
foundation just
as spelling and grammar are important
for
writing but that's not all there is to
good writing
and math there's more than just the
computation
we have wonderful tools now like
mathematica that do a great job at
computation
and we need to spend more time with
students up here at the upper end
working with the higher order thinking
skills working in problem solving and
communication
most of the time that i give a talk we
talk about the pedagogy
and what we're doing in the class except
here today we're more interested
in the other half of my class the part
that i don't really
deal with um watch videos
do some homework how can we have a tool
like mathematica
help the students learn those procedures
evaluate how well the students are doing
on that
and help the students learn by
pushing as much as we can over to the
computer side let the computers do what
they're good at
and let the teachers do what um teachers
do best
the first year we used a publisher's
product
and it took about a year to realize that
we needed something better
so we started looking around we were
using pearson's
mymathlab it cost
students 109 caused some problems in the
fact
that students have delays in financial
aid and so they don't have the product
right away and so they can't really
begin class for a couple weeks
and they forget their password and all
those technological issues that just
stand in the way of teaching um
plus side in one sense if the professor
doesn't want to put a lot of work
into it you get a product that's what
you're going to use you don't have to
think much about it you just send
students off to do some homework
you don't really worry about the content
you just
go right along uh one downside i saw to
that
is that the questions that my students
were doing were questions that
the publisher wanted them to do not the
questions that i wanted them to do
i wanted to have some local authority as
to what it was that i was asked
uh asking the students there also were
some
issues with uh the interpretation this
evaluation engine
uh one of the notable cases was asking
students what the
sign of 330 degrees is and my students
say
that is a fraction whose numerator is
negative
one and whose denominator is two and the
system said no
that is wrong it is a negative number
that is a fraction
whose numerator is one and whose
denominator is two
the system didn't recognize these two
things as being the same
leading one of my tas to taunt the
system saying
come on my grandmother can parse better
than that so
we needed a better system web work
maa project it's got a lot of positive
things to it
it's free to the students you do need
some service space at your institution
in order to run it
but it's open source i can
grab the wonderful question bank that
gavin the rose at michigan wrote
and start using those questions and it
works well for a certain part of our
population
but it's the part of the population
that's already well versed with
mathematics
they need to learn a lot of syntax just
have to know that s q
r t parentheses is the thing you're
going to need to do for square roots
you can write your own questions in web
work but you pretty much need to be an
expert in programming in perl which i am
not
uh i am a low-level programmer
and so we needed something easy for
instructors to
add content to a third thing we looked
at
at the time 2014 we were a moodle school
and there's this product uh chris
sanguin and others
over in england uh an add-on called
stack again free to students which we
like open source which we like
again students needed to learn some
syntax in order to
input answers but um
had a lot of neat features to it kind of
a lot of good innovation to it
once again you had to be a pretty
sophisticated programmer to
put content in and the one thing that
really drove us away from our
technical people's viewpoint was moodle
wasn't going to be around
for much longer and it turned out they
were right minnesota switched
to canvas in 2018 and is no longer
supporting moodle
so we needed something better and i
stumbled upon this i stumbled upon the
wolfham
alpha pro problem generator looked like
it had a couple of the components that i
needed
there's a question bank didn't have a
lot of questions in it that was going to
be a problem
but i could take care of the authoring
if the authoring was simple enough
and there's a student interface looks
pretty nice
uh mathematica wonderful engine to
determine whether the student
answer is correct and then we just had
to figure a way to
spit out the gradebook so after talking
with the wolfram folks for a while
we went forward with this project onshu
manic
now calvin mischo managing the project
we work with chad knutson for years now
danny finn
and um victory pain are helping us
with this project and it's been a
wonderful project for
us so here's what we have
question authoring uh at wednesday's
night award presentation
stephen wolf from talked about how i
would have an idea in the morning and be
able to
put it into action quickly and that's a
fairly
common story um i want to get something
going right away i have an idea
and i can type something up in a few
minutes
upload it put in an assignment i can
have an idea at 8
30 and be able to implement it in my
classroom by nine o'clock
fairly simple system you can define
random variables you can define
an integer in a certain range you can
pick randomly from a list
if you want to
refer to something a little simpler that
has a multi-step process i can define
further variables i want to talk about
red ping-pong balls and blue ping-pong
balls
and the total so i can talk about the
total ping-pong balls and
do that computation off of other random
variables
and then you just start typing away a
lot of this is text
some of this is mathematica code you can
embed graphics we even have a few
questions that
include manipulate in them and
there's a question
show the answer students can go to work
or you can be a little more
sophisticated
i've learned a few tricks to kind of
keep the questions that i
want one of the problems with
mathematica is that sometimes
too good at this job if i write this
fraction that has
x minus c in both the numerator and the
denominator mathematical will realize
oh i can simplify that and i don't want
it to because that's the point of the
question i want the students to factor
and simplify down here
so a few tricks to keep things looking
the way that you want to do it
but didn't take me long font size so
that it's readable down here
and here's a question that's displayed
to the students
or go crazy here is fairly
sophisticated code that produces random
graphics
here's a question solve a triangle
warning this picture is not necessarily
to scale
no it is this picture is the correct
picture because the coding
took the parameters and drew an
appropriate picture
so um do as little
programming or as much as you want to
make things look however you want
students need to be able to answer the
questions
we've worked on a palette interface
some improvements could still be made
here make this look a little prettier
but it does the job we don't get a lot
of issues with the students
we work out a problem the answer is
going to have a square root in it
student just hits the square root button
yes you still need to have the
mathematica code in your answer blank
but by hitting this button you get what
you need you get sqrt
and the brackets you need to move your
cursor in here so you can start typing
that
once you come outside the box it'll show
you what
it thinks you've written so students
here will often
oh they missed the parentheses and the
45 is only on half of this
expression and they realize they better
put some parentheses in here to get what
they need
students have been pretty capable of
figuring out how to make their answers
look like the way that they need them to
and write the math that they need to
we need to determine whether what the
student wrote is
correct one of the things that
we kind of finesse past the students but
would like a solution to
is sometimes mathematica is too good
we ask the students what the sign of pi
over 6 is
and i'm hoping that they've memorized
the unit circle and they'll answer one
half
they could type in 0.5 that would be
fine
but i can make them be specific on
sine of pi over 3. they need square root
3 over 2 they can't use a decimal
approximation but
they could also just type in the
question they could answer sine of pi
over 6 and mathematically would know
yes the sine of pi over 6 is one-half
and that does match what the professor
wrote down as the answer
and so we're looking for some ways that
we can
specify certain forms that are allowed
on certain types of problems
and here's the grade report the student
gets back
it shows exactly what they typed in
it shows how the answer got interpreted
notice that mathematica did do this much
the square root of 32
got simplified to write a better
expression
this is sometimes a good teaching moment
for the students they see that what's
parsed here is different than what they
typed
and they may now realize oh yeah there
are rules for
simplifying square roots this winds up
being a pretty good teaching tool as
well
compared to the correct answer and they
can see what their mistake is
what types of things can we ask students
to do
we can ask them to input answers which
are numbers
which for me in pre-calculus i by and
large mean a real number
but it works equally well for complex
numbers
research-wise i did my phd thesis in
combinatorial game theory
so just for fun i think it would be kind
of cool to
um john conway donald knuth
surreal numbers and berla camp conway
and
guy the the games if we could do
computations on games as a bigger set
the numbers i think that would be pretty
cool
but that's just for fun for the teaching
purposes
mathematical functions are important and
it can tell whether one function is
equal to another function
you can use text strings as
the way that you're evaluating the
answer though that's not very useful
the answer might be x plus two and the
student types in
x plus two and it sure did sound like i
said the right answer but you didn't
realize that i left a little pause in
there
if the cursor isn't in the right spot
and there's an invisible space
showing up in the character string then
it gets counted wrong so
we don't use that very often
we do have the ability to take
multi-part
answers so if the answer is a set
we can handle that case though it's not
quite as nice as we'd like it to be
we don't use the squiggly braces
the way that students would typically
write sets you just separate things with
commas and they
have to learn a little bit of syntax
there and it doesn't
look like it typically would the the way
a typical
student would typically write it out
some things that are
on my wish list i'd like to be able to
ask
students questions where their answer is
an infinite set
find all the angles where the sign is
one-half i'd like the students to be
able to
list a couple of answers that get us
started
tell us that the pattern repeats every
so often and then evaluate whether that
set
matches the answer key i've seen
a couple of presentations this week that
were very good
about examineer and a function that's
being loaded into the mathematica
platform
that would make the um
answer field a little bit more robust in
terms of how it evaluates things
there are certain cases like
factoring questions where maybe you
factor
out a negative one and then write down
the other factors
and we need to propose both
possible ways of factoring because the
two solutions are going to look
differently if you give me a list of
factors without the negative one and you
give me a list of factors with the
negative one
the factor lists are going to be
different and mathematic is going to
realize that the factors are different
but they are both correct factorizations
of the same polynomial
so um there's uh one thing on our wish
list that we're
hoping to get in the future
and then the final step um it turns out
there are some issues here originally i
thought
how hard can this be just spit it out
into a spreadsheet
uh turns out the database is probably
the preferable way to do it
and we have a very good database there
actually are
quite a few issues on the gradebook side
mostly dealing with security
but for the most part that's on the side
of the institution to
to work with the data security people
in terms of the instructors knowing how
the students have performed
and the students knowing how well
they've performed
it is as simple as just recording the
scores in a database and presenting that
data
how are we currently using this
our placement exam
about 7 000 students annually we've been
running it for
five years now we're approaching 40 000
students that have taken our placement
exam
the reporting goes directly into our
advisors hands and
they can seamlessly place students
into their first math class at the
university of minnesota
we use it in our pre-calculus classes
currently 600 students a year
and it saves our teaching assistants a
lot of time they're no longer having to
collect and grade
this routine homework students get
better feedback because they're getting
instant
feedback teaching assistants can spend
more of their time
working with more involved questions and
giving students feedback on their
on their writing we are
using this as a way to
prepare the students that are in our
sequence
they may need some help refreshing
themselves on
pre-calculus topics this review material
is available to the students they can
go back and review the topics they need
help with as they're getting ready for
calculus and it really has been
a benefit to us both in the spring
and this semester we've needed to move
away
from in-person pencil and paper exams
and this system has given us an
alternative
to delivering exams to
students in a reasonable way that
students
can show us what they know and not have
to deal with a lot of
technology concerns
the future we
welcome partnerships with others that
are interested in these same types of
things
in particular a lot has been done in
open educational resources and elsewhere
to work on delivering content
but they typically are lacking
the assessments they're typically
lacking the problem sets
so we would like to find ways that we
can share
the questions that we've written with
others and if we can
share with them crowdsource the content
so that we can get a lot of content
and deliver to students we think that
would be a worthwhile project
encouraged by some of the comments i've
heard this week
about the k-12 market i really think
this is a
a market that um really is wide open
for um for innovation
41 states in the united states have
the common core and that really is the
issue
k through 12 is aligning the assessments
to
to the common core standards and
benchmarking everything
and then there are a few other states
that go off and do
what they want to most noticeably is my
state minnesota
which is fairly notorious for kind of
going off and doing their own thing
but we have something similar to the
common core and aligning to those
standards is something that our k-12
schools need
and um working uh working to build
develop things in that field i think is
a
is a is a big opportunity as i mentioned
before
sometimes we need to ask for a specific
form from students to disallow them
using
functions allow them to use addition
subtraction multiplication division
square roots but not allow them to use
the sine function in their answer
mentioned also before these other issues
of
it'll be great to have the answer field
be able to
parse things out in terms of a variety
of different answers so if the student
says this we're going to give them half
credit
if the in a probability question if they
got the denominator right we'll give
them half credit
um and
other forms of the answer being
acceptable
the ability to write infinite sets i
think
provides an interesting programming
challenge
and we're busy working on
solutions to that so with that
i would like to thank everybody
for attending my contact
information is here and randall has
been monitoring the
chat window here if you have any
questions about this system
please please ask
the only thing that's been posted is
nam joshi says many k-12 schools use
google classroom and canvas
yeah there's some there's always the
issues
one of the other big issues with the
schools is they want this lms
integration we have not bothered to
to do that integration yet um but
but that certainly is um is an
issue for um making this work large
scale
um like i said minnesota is currently a
canvas school
um it isn't all that difficult to
uh to transfer this data back and forth
um so i think that's um that's
definitely a uh
a problem that can be can be solved with
a a little bit of work i would think
okay uh craig says can you talk about
the marketing dispute system that you
use in conjunction with the results of
the exam system
students disputing results
uh can you can you repeat that one more
time can you talk about the marketing
dispute system that you use in
conjunction with the results of the
exam system students disputing results
um we haven't done anything
sophisticated yet for the most part the
students
send the instructor an email and the
instructor
looks at the issue originally
when we wrote the questions yeah there
were a few questions
where the answer key was incorrect um
and we've we've corrected those
yeah for them for the most part here i
think this is part of the philosophy
behind
it that things that require
certain interpretation we expect the
students to
show their work in a certain way that's
not really what this
system is designed to do
anything that that has some subjective
evaluation to that we leave that in the
instructor's hands
this really is can you correctly
calculate an answer to this and
for the most part um there really isn't
a whole lot to dispute
if the answer to this question is the
square root of three over two then
that's what the answer is
so at this point yeah we're not trying
to use mathematica
as a discussion conversation
dispute resolution tool we rely on our
lms and our email system to
to handle those sorts of questions
okay matt says
you said you use the manipulates are
those flash based and if so
how do you deal with compatibility
issues
now that you mention it yeah we have not
used the manipulate recently
and now that i hear that question i
believe that that is exactly the issue
that i think we started running into the
problems because yes i believe that they
were
flash based and then that was the
you know that was the drawback was that
we were
we were having trouble with the
manipulates working on on
various platforms so um yes
good question and now that i think about
it more deeply
i think i think that is an issue that
that we never did resolve that that i
believe that they were flash based
and i think we've abandoned them for the
time being because of the
compatibility issues
craig says are students allowed to use
alternative technologies during exam
taking
such as calculators we are
moving toward um
making as much use of technology in the
classroom
as possible so um
we are basing more of our grade
on things that they do
in discussions in class and a lesser
percentage of the grade on
high stakes pencil and paper exams
um we do use mastery based grading and
this
this i think has been one of the best
features of
an automated system is that rule is very
simple in my class
your homework score needs to be one
hundred percent if your homework score
is not a hundred percent by the end of
the semester
your grade is f you must eventually get
every homework question correct
they can try them as many times as they
want they can come to office hours they
get help
students actually get done with this
stuff but now they
they know what's at stake and so they
spend time making sure that they know
how to do the
um how to do the computational stuff
um no one else just posted anything so
okay and my 30 minutes is uh
just about up here so once again i would
like to
thank everybody for for attending here
and i'm looking forward to continuing
this discussion
you